hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut ihr könnt
schon sehen ich habe mal wieder
eingekauft und ich dachte mir das ist
doch eigentlich mal ein Video wert auch
wenn man natürlich sagen musste Amazon
Prime day 2022 ist jetzt leider schon
vorbei dennoch gibt es auf das ein oder
andere Produkt was ich hier bestellt
habe immer noch Rabatt und ich dachte
mir wir machen einfach mal so ein
Unboxing also wird jetzt nichts wildes
aber ich gebe mir Mühe das ist lustig
wird Amazon Prime day war letzte Woche
es gab viele Sachen mit de Rabatt also
ich habe ordentlich losgeschossen bis zu
50 60 % alles was ich so gebrauchen kann
oder was halbwegs cool aussah und ich
würde sagen wir packen einfach mal aus
und so ganz genau weiß ich auch nicht
mehr was wo drin ist aber wird es schon
ganz lustig die Sachen verlinke ich euch
alle in der Videobeschreibung und wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal ob das Licht
auch überzeugt halt wenn ich jetzt so
real sehe ich würde sagen wir arbeiten
uns einfach mal vor von klein zu groß
zack ja was waren das noch mal das ist
immer das Beste wenn man zu viel
bestellt dann weiß man auch gar nicht
mehr was da genau eigentlich so dabei
war eine Sache habe ich noch im Kopf
Unterhosen weil Mama beschwert sich
immer dass ich keine Unterhose mehr
hätte und dann nehme ich immer die von
meinem Bruder und ja ich soll mir
unbedingt mal neu bestellen immer wenn
du das siehst das habe ich jetzt getan
ich hoffe die müssen eigentlich dabei
sein ja ja ja ja so ein Gerät womit ich
meine Haare im Gesicht wegmachen kann
das war nämlich ganz dick runtergesetzt
macht jetzt nicht so die besten
qualitätsanscheinen so hier einmal für
euch ich habe nämlich manchmal so zum
Beispiel hier habe ich so Haare oder
auch so hier die so gar nicht dahin
passen klar die können dich weg rasieren
aber dann dachte ich mir bestelle ich
mir noch mal hier sondern facial Harry
Mover guck mal ich glaube eigentlich der
ist eher für Frauen aber gut ist ja auch
sicherlich bei mir einsetzbar so der
läuft schon glaube ja das sind ja nur
Ersatzteile eigentlich alles bestens
jetzt schauen wir mal vorsichtig oh ihr
könnt mich als gut sehen hier habe ich
nämlich Haare
[Musik]
ich habe funktioniert ja optimal jetzt
sind die weg oder ist ja auch menschlich
dass man hier halt Haare hat machen wir
mal noch einen Test hier wo ich mehr
habe aber
nehme ich schon eben lieber meinen
Rasierer also unterm Strich muss man
sagen das ist halt für Frauen Haare
denke ich mal die so ein bisschen Haare
im Gesicht haben mich zu beharrt sind
wie ich da kann man den dann mal
benutzen ansonsten für mich macht es
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so viel Sinn
nächstes Produkt das war doch ein Vlog
ich muss wirklich manchmal sagen lies
dir auch gerne Kommentare von Euch und
manchmal steht da sowas hätte ich mal
wieder besser informieren müssen wie
immer irgendwie schon manchmal ist halt
einfach mein Problem denkt nicht nach
und Denken okay das wird richtig cool
ich mache das einfach jetzt so und so
dann ist es in meinem Kopf verankert als
wäre es richtig cool und erst dann wenn
jemand sagt okay das war doch nicht ganz
so cool dann checke ich ja was habe ich
mir eigentlich dabei gedacht mach mal
weiter mit der nächsten Sache was haben
wir denn hier das ist ganz schön schwer
ist aber kriminell Scotch Whisky ich
muss sagen der war richtig reduziert und
den habe ich dann einfach mal
mitgenommen wir haben jetzt gerade 13
Uhr trotzdem ich bin auch gar nicht so
krass der Whisky Fan aber ich habe jetzt
schon in letzter Zeit hin und wieder
Whiskey probiert und der hat mich
irgendwie angelacht das ist natürlich
erst am 18 das muss man ganz klar sagen
Leute das wird jetzt natürlich nicht in
der Videobeschreibung verlinkt aber wir
probieren den wenigstens einmal man muss
ja als Youtuber irgendwie durch den Tag
kommen und wenn man so ein bisschen
Alkohol im Büro hat haben wir ja schon
bei dem ein oder anderen Youtuber mal
gehört das ist wichtig ist auch mein
leckeren gesunden Tropfen ja im Büro zu
haben ja schatzkäse haben wir hier nicht
aber ist auch nicht so schlimm probieren
wir mal wirklich nur ein ganz kleinen
Schluck und den stelle ich dann hier bei
mir im Kühlschrank ich weiß nicht
irgendwann hat man natürlich auch mal
ein Anlass wo man was feiern kann oder
so da kann man den ja dann mal probieren
so auf euch und offen weiter gelungenes
Video
ja mega das war vielleicht auch das
nächste Produkt wo man sagen kann warum
habe ich das bestellt es war gut
reduziert und ja genau so wie auch zum
Beispiel das nächste Dingen wir haben
hier ich freue mich schon drauf hast mal
auf Leute für die die sich auskennen ihr
könnt schon sehen roborock den gibt es
nämlich aktuell auch sehr reduziert vor
allem am Prime day das Gute ist auch
noch nach dem Prime day habe ich am
Anfang schon gesagt okay Leute ich mache
den erstmal auf aber das müsste der
roborock S7 sein für 479 € gibt es den
aktuell bei Amazon und dieses Angebot
hat am Prime der gestartet geht noch
weiter darüber hinaus und bei Kaufland
ist der aktuell auch reduziert das
wollte ich schon mal gesagt haben das
nämlich ganz wichtig den habe ich mir
auch bestellt in Weiß wir schauen uns
jetzt mal zusammen an ihr wisst ja mit
Saugrobotern kenne ich mich auch Honig
Mobbing autolifting Mob und das geile
ist zusammen mit roborock darf ich am
Ende des Videos oder halt gleich auch
ein Exemplar verlosen deswegen wenn ihr
schon immer mal ein Saugroboter haben
wollte bleibt auf jeden Fall kurz noch
dran schauen wir einfach mal rein das
gleiche Modell zum Verlosen habe ich
auch in schwarz bekommen wobei ich weiß
nicht ihr könnt euch dann einen
aussuchen bzw der ob ihr in weiß oder
schwarz wollt wenn euch jetzt auch ein
paar Beauty Shots ein wenn der roborock
unterwegs ist hier haben wir auf jeden
Fall einmal so ein Unterteller damit der
Boden auch schön sauber ist da wo er
halt sich auflädt Beschreibung hier ist
der Wischmop genau der kann wischen und
saugen gleichzeitig auch ganz wichtig
und dann machen wir das einmal ab und
hier haben wir dann den S7 den es
übrigens auch als S7 Plus gibt da habt
ihr dann noch so eine Absaugstation
dabei ist dann natürlich ein bisschen
teurer aber den gibt es aktuell auch im
Angebot was ich schon direkt sehr nice
finde ihr wisst ja ich habe schon viele
Saugroboter getestet wir haben hier auch
eine Gummibürste bei das ist sehr sehr
hilfreich weil dann verfangen sich nicht
so schnell Kabel unterm Baum könnt euch
eine App auf Smartphone ziehen die
roborock App den damit verbinden und
dann geht's auch schon los hier haben
wir noch die Ladestation es ist einfach
designtechnisch und schöner Saugroboter
und auch gleichzeitig ein schönes
Accessoires für eure Wohnung oder euer
Haus wie ich gerade schon gesagt habe
ich habe auch den schwarzen den seht ihr
jetzt gerade wahrscheinlich rumfahren
oftmals ist ja bei Saugrobotern mit
Wischfunktion das Problem dass der
Schmutz trotzdem nicht ganz weggeht wenn
ihr z.B Kaffeeflecken oder so auf dem
Boden habt der S7 schrubbt eure Böden
mit bis zu 3 mal pro Minute also damit
kann man muss wirklich gut entfernen ihr
könnt hier Wasser rein füllen zack in
dieses Ding und könnt eurem S7 dann
sagen dass er gleichzeitig saugen und
wischen soll da kann man verschiedene
Stufen einstellen wie stark das sein
soll ihr könnt alle Teppich und so
weiter liegen lassen das ist ganz egal
denn der S7 erkennt wenn er beim Teppich
fährt dann wird der intelligente Mob
leicht angehoben und das Wischen mit
Wischwasser natürlich kurz ausgesetzt
bis er wieder festen Boden unter den
Füßen hat also das ist wirklich nice man
braucht sich nicht wirklich viel drum
kümmern und irgendwelche besonderen
Einstellungen treffen der S7 misst
automatisch eure Zimmer aus erstellt
euch Karten die roborock App und ihr
könnt dann immer auswählen welche Etage
in welches Zimmer soll er zuerst fahren
wie stark soll er da wischen ihr könnt
bis zu vier Karten hinter einem roborock
verstecken also quasi wenn ihr jetzt zum
Beispiel vier Etagen habt könnt ihr das
alles speichern und euren roborock
einfach auch mal in eine andere Etage
stellen und dann weiß er genau wo er ist
und legt da los das geile ist hier der
weiße total unbenutzt wird der ist für
euch hat einfach einen netten Kommentar
warum wir den haben wollt like das Video
und schreibt auch gerne euren Instagram
Namen dazu damit ich euch kontaktieren
kann dann löse ich das bald auf und
kontaktiere den Gewinner und hier machen
jetzt weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt
ich bin schon ganz gespannt ich sag hier
steht's nochmal 12 bis 13 juli ist
leider vorbei hier sind mehrere Sachen
gleichzeitig drin was habe ich mir dann
oben fragt mich nicht warum ich mir
Pickups bestellt habe aber ich weiß
nicht ich finde die übelst nice und das
sind so Pickups mit schwarzer Schokolade
24 Stück die waren so günstig da konnte
ich einfach nicht nein sagen auch hier
für mein Büro wenn ich mal Gäste da zum
Empfang ist das ganz wichtig wobei einen
esse ich jetzt und der Rest kommt den
Kühlschrank das ist irgendwie auch so
eine Angewohnheit von mir dass ich
Süßigkeiten grundsätzlich immer im
Kühlschrank packe obwohl man das ja gar
nicht muss manchmal ist ja auch scheiße
weil da sind sie halt voll hart wenn man
die Essen will.Ich habe mir Socken
bestellt entschuldigung ich weiß dass
jetzt nicht so interessant für euch aber
für mich ist es was ganz besonderes
endlich mal wieder ich glaube ich habe
mir noch nie selber Socken gekauft guck
mal hier in weiß grau schwarz war auch
günstig an die Fußfetischisten unter
euch wenn ihr wollt kann ich dir sogar
weiterverkaufen nachdem ich sie dann
abgetragen habe weil ich frage mich
sowieso immer oftmals schon so Löcher in
meine Socken und dann schmeiße ich die
weg aber ich weiß ja dass der Markt
dafür auch gigantisch ist deswegen wenn
ich meine getragenen Socken haben wollt
schreib mir einfach mal bei Instagram
meine ich übrigens Ernst ne also ich
habe damit jetzt eigentlich kein Problem
Europa ich will damit kein großes
Geschäft machen ich will dir einfach nur
nicht wegschmeißen okay
Überwachungskamera ja ich weiß dass ich
auch öfter schon mal Überwachungskameras
gekauft habe oder irgendwo in Paketen
drin hatte aber das hier ist eine die
kann ich schön für meine Wohnung stellen
weil das habe ich schon bei Freunden
gesehen dann kann man immer sehen wenn
da irgendwie ein ungebetener Gast vorbei
läuft da kannst du dir auch eine App
aufs Handy ziehen genau Christian halt
immer eine Notification ich habe für das
Dinge nicht mehr 30 € bezahlt und die
sind absolut in Ordnung das ist sogar
gut gemacht hier hinten ist direkt ein
QR-Code drauf wird einen dann
irgendwohin wo man nichts öffnen kann ja
super perfekt und wie gesagt ich kenne
viele andere Youtube Kollegen die sowas
zu Hause haben und dann halt sehen
können wenn irgendwas doofes passiert
eventuell weil man ganz viele teure
Weltkriegen Channel zu Hause hat ah ja
ja das fand ich auch ganz gut und zwar
ist das eine Mini Soundbar für mein
MacBook beziehungsweise auch hier für
mein Büro weil ich habe mir hier das
können wir vielleicht erstmal aufmachen
habe ich mir noch einen Zusatztisch
bestellt der hat einfach nice aussieht
wo ich meinen Macbook drauf stellen kann
wo ich diese Soundbar drauf stellen kann
wo ich mein Handy drauflegen kann und es
sieht einfach nur flippig und nice aus
das hat mich direkt überzeugt und war
auch wirklich nicht teuer und da habe
ich das einfach mal gekauft ach so und
die Sound war halt dazu damit ich auch
mal hier geile Musik hören kann aha das
sieht doch schon gut aus das ist einfach
so ein Tisch oh nein hier ist ja was
kaputt gegangen oh Mist schaut mal echt
scheiße beschädigt ihr guckt mal was
mache ich da jetzt kann ich das
vielleicht wieder rein drücken nee das
geht nur weiter kaputt oh mann das ist
aber schade na ja gut wollen wir mal
nicht rumheulen war auch günstig die
mehr war das jetzt nicht ah okay ja ja
das kann man einfach schnell
zusammenstecken so und ging das so ah ja
ja das ist ja wie so eine Schiene und
dann kannst du es so wenden dann das
gleiche noch auf der anderen Seite dann
kann man da hier z.B das iMac drauf
stellen dann die Soundbar hier drunter
Tastatur ich bau das mal zusammen und
dann zeige ich euch okay Leute ich habe
das jetzt immer aufgebaut ich muss sagen
es sieht echt richtig stylisch aus
gefällt mir sehr sehr gut einziges
Problem dieses Soundbar ist voll scheiße
mein iMac macht ein viel besseren Sound
das hätte ich natürlich nicht gedacht
kurzer Soundcheck erster Test mit
Soundbar
und jetzt ohne
[Musik]
aber egal Hauptsache sieht geil aus aber
ich werde das jetzt auf jeden Fall
erstmal so lassen und wir sind noch zwei
weitere Pakete angekommen die habe ich
schon fast vergessen wobei nein so ganz
vergessen habe ich nicht wo sind meine
Unterhosen hier haben wir einmal sechs
nigelnagelneue Unterhosen für mich geil
schwarz nee nee nee warte mal ganz kurz
ich habe die auch in grau und weiß
bestellt ich will weiße Boxershorts die
kommen viel besser an als schwarze und
dann ist das hier leider das letzte
Paket was ich bestellt habe und ich weiß
aber gar nicht genau was oh nein oh mein
oh mein Gott was ist damit denn passiert
Alter also ich hatte sowas einmal
bereits kann man halt leider nicht immer
verhindern wir haben hier die gute
hellmanns Mayonnaise in vegan mit Bacon
Geschmack das wollte ich unbedingt mal
testen und die Wahrheit auch krass im
Angebot aber leider ist sie dermaßen
zerschallert oh Gott Alter ob ich
vielleicht mit vier von denen arbeiten
kann das wäre auch in Ordnung war ich
das alles wieder zurückschicken muss ja
auch nicht sein ne wobei schaut mal
Leute jetzt können wir direkt zum Test
machen ob das auch schmeckt noch ein
bisschen Mayo wie am Finger
ja
weiß nicht so ganz schmeckt irgendwie
nicht so gut ich benutze mal die normale
hell manchmal für meine Burger ich
glaube die ist nicht so mein Ding egal
ich werde die schon essen das war meine
Ausbeute vom diesjährigen Amazon Prime
day ich hoffe das Video war halbwegs
unterhaltsam für euch vergesst auf
keinen Fall beim roborock Gewinnspiel
mitzumachen alle Sachen sind in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt und checkt
den S7 gerne mal aus wir sehen uns bald
kommt schon das nächste Video haut rein
Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen ciao